hier habe ich hat bewegt das jetzt ab
morgen das erste mal in köln der muezzin
zum gebet ruft 35 moscheen können da vom
minarett oder bei anderen lautsprechern
zum gebet rufen allah ist groß das hat
mir in erinnerung gerufen dass wir uns
damals sehr geärgert haben als christen
in deutschland als deutsche bischöfe den
tempelberg besucht haben und ihre kreuze
abgelegt haben als zeichen der
religiösen toleranz das zentrale symbol
des christentums der gekreuzigte der
auferstandene abgelegt auf dem
tempelberg
gleichzeitig haben wir in deutschland
jetzt möglich gemacht dass man es gibt
das schon in anderen städten offensiv
zum gebet ruft und nicht nur wie es bei
kirchenglocken der fall ist ein signal
setzt jetzt gibt es den gottesdienst
auch die schulglocke ist letztlich nur
angelehnt an den ruf der kirchenglocke
der das islamische modell sieht vor dass
man ganz klar den eigenen gott preis und
das lautstark in der öffentlichkeit über
alle hinweg fallen lässt und das finde
ich etwas seltsam also sind wir tolerant
bis zur selbstaufgabe kann man nicht
seine religion leben so wie wir das
leben das man das ist privatsache ist
und dass sie nicht die öffentlichkeit
bescheiden muss ja erleben gerade dass
islamisten in öffentlichen sendern
runterkommen wir erleben gerade ein
attentat wieder mal in norwegen wo
jemand zum islam konvertiert ist und
sich radikalisiert hat die nine eleven
attentäter sind haben sich bei uns
radikalisiert wir erleben dass die
integration von muslimen sehr sehr
schwierig es werden eine islamkonferenz
werden dass bei keiner anderen religion
und da kommen mir in erinnerung dass
angela merkel mal gefragt wurde 20 15 im
herbst in einer veranstaltung in der
schweiz was sie denn gegen die
islamisierung europas tour und da hat
sie gesagt ja
man dürfe ja auch nicht verkennen dass
auch europäer in den heiligen krieg
gezogen seien nach syrien und
andererseits wenn die deutschen alle
wüssten was pfingsten ist und öfter in
den gottesdienst gehen würden dann wäre
das auch kein problem das ist so ein
seltsames verständnis schulterzuckend ja
gott sind sie zu stark sind wir zu
schwach wir gucken wir mal das ist mir
ehrlich gesagt zu wenig und die zweite
episode die mir da mal in den sinn kommt
ist dass angela merkel gesagt hat wenn
man sich dafür entschuldigen muss dass
man ein freundliches gesicht zeigt dann
sei das nicht mehr landen ich frage mich
eben auch manchmal ist es eigentlich
noch mein land wenn ich von nach dem
attentat am breitscheidplatz feststelle
das ist ganz ganz schwierig
islamistische täter wieder in ihr
heimatland abzuschieben wenn ich hass
prediger höre wenn ich zur kenntnis
nehmen dass die liberale moschee in
berlin von sehr artig unter bewachung
stehen muss damit sie nicht attackiert
wird wenn ich all diese probleme nehme
ist dann das ein gutes zeichen rest der
medizin in köln einer millionenstadt zum
gebet ruft ist dass die toleranz die wir
leben wollen oder ist es eigentlich
schon ein stück selbstaufgabe
ich würde die zustimmung iphone auch
sagen dass ein stück selbstaufgabe es
vor allem aber auch weil ich der festen
überzeugung bin dass für eine
funktionierende demokratie möglichst
wenig religion eine rolle spielen sollte
und als ich das gehört habe war ich auch
schockiert zugegebenermaßen weil ich
einfach glaube und es gab ein schmied
hat mich sehr berührt von unserer
unserer kollegin aus dem politik ressort
von chamier hakt das ist sie daran
erinnert ein was negatives erinnert es
an foltern schlimme sachen erinnert sie
verbindet das mit schlimmen sachen und
das ist glaube ich der punkt den wir
damit auch nicht vergessen dürfen auch
die die zu uns geflüchtet sind nicht nur
wir deutschen die vielleicht sagen es
passt nicht zu uns aber auch die
menschen die zu uns geflüchtet sind die
schutz suchen die erinnert dieser ruf
nicht an was positives viele von ihnen
wie dieser tweet aufgezeigt hat erinnert
dieser ruf auch ein etwas negatives und
ich glaube das ist auch ein ganz ganz
wichtiger punkt dass wir die diskussion
nicht nur auf uns projizieren und sagen
wir deutschen wir möchten wir auch sagen
die die zu uns geflüchtet sind die
müssen vielleicht auch davor geschützt
werden dass religion einen zu großen
einfluss und da ist was dran und was wir
auch viele verkennen in der pluralen
gesellschaft die wir nun sind wie tief
eigentlich das christentum unser
staatswesen prägt die würde des menschen
die anteilige 1 des grundgesetzes steht
ist eigentlich ein rückgriff auf die
eben bildlichkeit gott ist aus aus dem
neuen testament die die ganze unser
ganzes verständnis die andere wange
hinzuhalten ist ein zutiefst
christliches nicht zu vergleichen mit
dem
sagen wir mal aggressiv missionieren
denn impetus den es im alten testament
gegeben hat das hat unser staatswesen
zutiefst durchtränkt dass selbst ein
straftäter recht das recht hat
verteidigt zu werden und vor gericht
gehört zu werden und auch eben nicht
gequält oder bloßgestellt oder an den
pranger gestellt zu werden ein zutiefst
christliche verständnis und dann erlebe
ich eben dass erdogan unter türken der
zweiten dritten generation in
deutschland
mehrheiten bekommt wie sie zu im
heimatland nicht
vorhanden sind und ich erlebe dass es
große probleme gibt in bestimmten
communitys mit der säkularen staats
verfassung die wir haben ich erlebe
archaisches rollenverhalten und und
verhüllende bekleidungs kultur und ich
sehe nicht so richtig dass wir in der
lage sind in unserer freiheitlichen
demokratie das zu integrieren wir alle
würden uns dagegen verwahren wenn uns
jemand in die private lebensführung
reinreden würde und natürlich tun wir
das bei leuten die aus anderen ländern
kommen auch nicht aber die grenzen sind
mir etwas unklar also ihr wisst
vielleicht das in
arabischen ländern keine christlichen
kirchen gebaut werden dürfen das finde
ich schon allerhand also die tatsache
denn der ist also ich habe freunde die
beim diplomatischen dienst in riad sind
wir müssen im geheimen obwohl sie die
primaten sind wir müssen im geheimen
gottesdienste abhalten also im geheimen
im keller und wenn dann einen vom
philippinischen hauspersonal jemand dazu
kommen will frauen die sich nicht weil
dann das ist gefährlich und das ist ein
verbündeter von uns also ich finde das
schon bin ich finde ich finde das schon
also diese justice gerade angedeutet wir
sind extrem tolerant und öffnen unsere
arme und den arabischen ländern
findet zum teil einer christenverfolgung
statt und man darf man darf nicht frei
gottesdienst feiern da ist da ist
irgendwas läuft irgendetwas schief wenn
ich jetzt überlegt ich habe ehrlichkeit
mehr als ich nichts gegen medizin rufe
ich finde das bin ich hier bin ich ihnen
über sich im casablanca binger das finde
ich das sehr schöne in sarajevo dass man
wacht morgens auf alles ist sehr
malerisch nur in einer stadt wie köln
wird mir da irgendwie mulmig denn für
mich ist köln ja eines der ältesten
deutschen städte ich denke der römische
gründung ich der riesige dom in der
stadt und plötzlich gehst du durch die
stadt und wurst in medizin also da wenn
man da nicht deutlich wird dass dass die
zeiten sich sehr geändert haben und
womöglich nicht unbedingt zum besseren
und zum zur stärkung unserer eigenen
kultur
bisschen mulmig wird mir dabei schon
entweder wie sehen sie das also ich
teile die auffassung dass wir ganz klar
unsere werte in deutschland haben
übrigens auch die werte des
grundgesetzes
und wir sollten diese werte immer sehr
selbstbewusst hochhalten das fehlt mir
ein wenig bei den debatten insgesamt und
aus meiner sicht ist auch völlig klar
wer wir haben eine willkommenskultur in
deutschland aber wer hierhin kommt das
wird von uns erwartet dass man sich an
die regeln an die sitten an die werte
des jeweiligen landes bild zusammen in
deutschland dann auch dementsprechend
orientiert das ist die voraussetzung
dass unser land unsere gesellschaft
funktioniert köln ist eine wahnsinnig
tolle rannte und liberale stadt ich habe
selbst einige jahre in köln gelebt in
der zeit dort studiert dass es das
zusammenleben von menschen aus
unterschiedlichen nationen funktionierte
hervorragend und das wird auch so weiter
gehen unabhängig jetzt von von dieser
frage was mich mehr stören würde bei dem
themen oder was mich insgesamt in
deutschland stört ist dass wir
beispielsweise sehr eng beim thema
religion in zusammenhang mit dem islam
mit einer organisation arbeiten die im
grunde genommen von der vom türkischen
staat beeinflusst und geprägt wird denn
ich habe ein problem damit
beispielsweise auch in einer moschee zu
sein wo ich weiß im wesentlichen ist es
bestimmt von der türkischen
religionsbehörde
und da werden übrigens auch bestimmte
bestimmte muslime ja auch von vornherein
ausgeschlossen die islamisierung
deutschlands den begriff würde ich nicht
benutzen wird bei weil das nichts mit
der realität zu tun hat es gibt keine
islamisierung deutschlands also das ist
das also in dem begriff würde ich nicht
benutzen und die überwiegende mehrheit
der muslime in deutschland sind gut
integriert das problem in deutschland
ist aber oft dass man dafür sorgt medial
aber auch in der politik dass gerade
diejenigen die am lautesten schreien
dass die auch eine bühne bekommen das
ist aber die überwiegende mehrheit der
muslime in deutschland sind aber damit
nicht einfach wir hatten allerdings ja
die debatte ob der islam zu deutschland
gehört wenn wir an diese frage mit ja
beantwortet dann kann man sich nicht
aussuchen welcher islam zu deutschland
gehört und das ist ein riesenproblem das
problem hat frankreich in den bonus in
marseille zum teil deshalb belgien das
haben die niederlande und aber das
problem frankreich ist ja kein religion
kein problem der religion sondern es ist
eine soziale frage und diese frage ist
ja über viele viele jahre vernachlässigt
bei 1000 problem haben wir kooperieren
wäre ja auch also die radikalisierung
ist haben die talstation die in
frankreich existieren ja also die die
maßnahmen die rollen in nordrhein
westfalen gegen clans nimmt sind schon
relativ drastisch das problem ist ja
wenn jemand in einer
mehrheitsgesellschaft aufwächst von der
er sich nicht hundertprozentig
angenommen fühlt dass er dann
möglicherweise in der in die religion
eine
einen stolz projiziert und eine eine
orthodoxie entwickelt die in diaspora es
nicht selten ist also die deutschen im
ausland sind eigentlich auch deutscher
als die deutschen hier in singen lieder
die wir aber vorher nicht mehr sehen
würden und dieses problem kriegen wir
nicht in den griff und je schleichen da
die migration
fortbesteht und wir haben sie nach wie
vor nicht im griff
desto schwieriger wird es zu verhindern
dass prekäre milieus aufgefüllt werden
die probleme machen
[Musik]